BETTING ENOUGH, HARRIS
FAULKNER, TAKE IT AWAY.
>> Harris: DEMANDING ANSWERS,
ALL THE WAY TO CAPITOL HILL NOW.
WHY WAS A POWERFUL TEACHER’S
UNION SEEMINGLY ALOUD TO
DICTATE CDC POLICY ON WHEN
AMERICAN SCHOOLS COULD REOPEN?
I’M HARRIS FAULKNER.
20 HOUSE REPUBLICANS ARE LED BY
HOUSE MINORITY WHIP STEVE
SCALISE SAYING THEY ARE
LAUNCHING AN INVESTIGATION INTO
ALLEGED IMPROPER OUTSIDE
INFLUENCE ON THE CDC BY THE
AMERICAN FEDERATION OF TEACHERS.
RIGHT NOW ABOUT 1/3 OF STUDENTS
ACROSS THE COUNTRY ARE STILL
NOT BACK IN THEIR CLASSROOMS
FULL-TIME.
THE LAWMAKERS ARE ASKING CDC
CHIEF TO HAND OVER THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS WITH THE AFT.
THAT’S A MAJOR DEMOCRATIC DONOR.
SOME REPUBLICAN SENATORS
YESTERDAY QUESTIONED THE DOCTOR
OVER A REPORT SAYING THE AGENCY
USED FEEDBACK FROM THAT
TEACHERS UNION WORD FOR WORD IN
SOME PARTS OF CDC GUIDANCE.
>> WHY IS HAVING OFFLINE SECRET
NEGOTIATIONS WITH ONE
STAKEHOLDER.
>> AS A MATTER OF PRACTICE THE
CDC ENGAGES IF STAKEHOLDERS,
WITH CONSUMERS WHO TAKE OUR
GUIDANCE.
>> IT SUGGESTS THAT AFT
LEADERSHIP, THEY CERTAINLY
CHANGED THE LANGUAGE OF THE
GUIDANCE.
>> IT WAS THE CDC SCIENTISTS
THAT PROVIDED THE GUIDANCE THAT
PROVIDED THE SCIENCE AROUND
WHAT WE SHOULD DO.
>> Harris: STEVE SCALISE, HOUSE
MINORITY WHIP AND RANKING
REPUBLICAN IS HERE WITH ME NOW.
GREAT TO SEE YOU TODAY.
MY FIRST QUESTION IS, IS THE
CDC IN TROUBLE?
>> HARRIS, I THINK THE CDC IS
IN TROUBLE BECAUSE THEY’RE
BEING ASKED VERY SERIOUS
QUESTIONS AND GO BACK TO THE
CAMPAIGN.
PRESIDENT BIDEN SAID HE WOULD
FOLLOW THE SCIENCE.
HERE YOU HAD SCIENCE SAYING
MOST SCHOOLS COULD REOPEN.
THE SCIENTISTS WERE SAYING ALL
SCHOOLS SHOULD BE OPEN AND THEY
WERE GETTING READY TO COME OUT
WITH THAT AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
THE TEACHERS UNION SAID WAIT,
WE DON’T WANT TO HAVE TO GO
BACK INTO THE CLASSROOM.
AND LET STUDENTS BACK IN AND SO
YOU SAW THEM CHANGE IT.
THEY CHANGED THE BASIC METRICS
OF SCIENCE THAT WERE GOING TO
BE USED SO INSTEAD OF HAVING
MOST KIDS BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM, VERY FEW KIDS ABOUT
90% OF SCHOOLS STAYED CLOSED
BECAUSE OF THAT CHANGE IN
METRICS UNDERMINING THE SCIENCE.
IT WAS DONE BY THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION.
THEY HAVE YET TO ANSWER FOR IT.
WE’RE TRYING TO GET THOSE
COMMUNICATIONS BECAUSE THIS IS
HURTING KIDS.
IT IS HURTING MILLIONS OF KIDS
ACROSS AMERICA WHO MAY NEVER
MAKE UP THIS DIFFERENCE OF NOT
BEING IN THE CLASSROOM WHEN
THEY SHOULD BE AND SCIENCE SAYS
THEY NEED TO BE.
>> Harris: QUICKLY AND I WANT
TO MOVE ON TO A MORE BIG
PICTURE QUESTION BUT HOW
IMPORTANT OR CRITICAL IS IT TO
KNOW THAT THE AFT WAS A HUGE
DONOR, DEMOCRATIC DONOR?
>> IT’S VERY IMPORTANT AND
AGAIN SOMETHING THAT SHOULD BE
ON THE TABLE FOR DISCUSSION.
WHEN YOU HEARD PRESIDENT BIDEN
SAYING HE WAS GOING TO FOLLOW
THE SCIENCE AND ALL OF A SUDDEN
HE THROWS THE SCIENCE OUT THE
WINDOW BECAUSE A SPECIAL
INTEREST DONOR, THE TEACHERS
UNION, SAYS THAT THEY DON’T
WANT KIDS TO BE BACK IN THE
CLASSROOM LEARNING.
WE’RE SEEING THIS IN SO MANY
STATES WHERE PARENTS ARE JUST
RISING UP EVEN IN BERKELEY WHEN
THE TEACHERS UNION HEAD IS
TELLING ALL THE TEACHERS DON’T
GO TO CLASS, YOU CAN’T BE IN
THE CLASSROOM AND THEN THEY SEE
HIM TAKING HIS KIDS TO PRIVATE
SCHOOL IN THE CLASSROOM THAT
DOUBLE STANDARD IS JUST --
PEOPLE ARE GOING LIVID BECAUSE
THEY KNOW IT IS HURTING THEIR
KIDS AND THEY’RE WATCHING THE
UNION HEADS TAKE STEPS THAT GO
AGAINST THE KIDS.
SAN FRANCISCO, JUST TO GET A
MONEY GRAB IS GOING TO GO IN
THE CLASSROOM FOR ONE DAY SO IT
SHOWS YOU THEY CAN BE IN THE
CLASSROOM IF IT’S ABOUT
GRABBING A BUNCH OF MONEY.
IF IT’S ABOUT HELPING YOUR KIDS
THEY AREN’T IN THE CLASSROOM.
THIS IS A DANGEROUS PLACE TO
SEE.
WHAT THEY’RE DOING LONG TERM
DAMAGE FOR OUR KIDS.
>> Harris: WHAT YOU ARE TALKING
ABOUT IN SAN FRANCISCO THEY’LL
OPEN UP THE SCHOOLS TO QUALIFY
FOR THE CASH AND GO RIGHT BACK
TO WHERE THEY WERE AGAIN.
TONS OF QUESTIONS ABOUT THAT.
I WANT TO GO, 37,000 FEET, THE
BIG PICTURE.
THERE SEEMS TO BE HEAT BUILDING
HERE.
YOU HAVE ALL OF THIS OVER THE
COVID-19 SCHOOL CLOSURES AND
THE OVERALL HANDLING OF THE
PANDEMIC BY THIS CURRENT
ADMINISTRATION.
TROUBLE GETTING AMERICANS BACK
TO WORK, REPRESENTATIVE SCALISE.
A MASSIVE CRISIS ON THE
SOUTHERN BORDER, VIOLENCE
EXPLODING IN THE MIDDLE EAST,
PIPELINE HACK CAUSING PANIC
BUYING OF GASOLINE.
THE LIST IS A LITTLE LONGER
THAN THAT.
THE BIG PICTURE LEADERSHIP FROM
THE WHITE HOUSE, WHERE IS IT?
ARE AMERICANS HEARING ENOUGH
FROM PRESIDENT BIDEN?
>> IT’S NON-EXISTENT.
YOU MENTIONED A NUMBER OF
CRISES WE’RE SAYING.
THE PRESIDENT WON’T ACKNOWLEDGE
AND GO DOWN TO THE BORDER.
GAS PRICES THROUGH THE ROOF AND
PEOPLE WAITING IN LINE.
THERE WAS A MAJOR HACK BY
RUSSIA LIKELY.
PRESIDENT BIDEN DOESN’T WANT TO
CONFRONT THAT.
YOU LOOK AT HOME PRICES.
BECAUSE OF LUMBER PRICES GOING
THROUGH THE ROOF AN AVERAGE
HOME IS OVER $36,000 MORE THAN
IT WAS A YEAR AGO.
LOOK WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
UNEMPLOYMENT.
8 MILLION JOBS ARE UNFILLED
RIGHT NOW AND PRESIDENT BIDEN
JUST USHERED THROUGH A PARTISAN
BILL TO PAY PEOPLE BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS NOT TO WORK WHEN 8
MILLION JOBS ARE UNFILLED RIGHT
NOW.
WE’RE PAYING PEOPLE NOT TO WORK
AND THEY’RE BORROWING MONEY
FROM OUR KIDS AND GRANDKIDS TO
DO IT.
WE’RE SEEING IT ON EVERY FRONT.
THE ECONOMY IS REALLY IN A
DELICATE SPOT.
WE SEE INFLATION STARTING TO GO
THROUGH THE ROOF.
OUR COUNTRY IS LESS SECURE.
LOOK WHAT IS HAPPENING AROUND
THE WORLD.
WHO THE PRESIDENT WANTS TO LET
BACK INTO AN AGREEMENT TO GET A
NUCLEAR WEAPON.
THEY’RE HELPING FUNNEL THESE
BOMBS BEING SHOT INTO ISRAEL.
WHERE IS THE PRESIDENT’S
LEADERSHIP ON ANY OF THESE
CRISES?
>> Harris: WHERE IS HE TO
ANSWER THE QUESTIONS ON ALL
THIS?
SPECIFICALLY WITH IRAN AND
WHAT’S GOING ON BETWEEN THE
PALESTINIANS AND ISRAEL RIGHT
NOW.
WHAT’S BREAKING OFF INTO A VERY
VOLATILE SITUATION THIS WEEK
ALONE.
WE CAN’T HAVE ACCESS THROUGH
OUR PRESS CORPS TO THE
PRESIDENT OF THE UNITED STATES
TO ASK ABOUT HOW THE IRANIAN
AGREEMENT OR NEGOTIATION
AFFECTS OR INFECTS POLICY
TOWARD WHAT’S HAPPENING WITH
ISRAEL.
WE HAVE JEN PSAKI.
THAT’S NOT PRESIDENT BIDEN SO
WE THINK.
>> SHE IS TRYING TO ENCOURAGE
HIM NOT TO ANSWER QUESTIONS.
>> Harris: THAT’S WHAT WE’RE
HEARING.
IF THERE IS SOMETHING
DIFFERENT, SHOW US.
HOUSE HEARING UNDERWAY RIGHT
NOW.
THE TOPIC ON VIOLENT EXTREMISM
AND THE RESPONSE ON THE JANUARY
6th CAPITOL RIOT.
CONGRESSMAN, AS THIS UNFOLDS
YOU’RE ASKING THE F.B.I. TO
REOPEN THE INVESTIGATION INTO
THE 2017 SHOOTING AT THAT
VIRGINIA BASEBALL FIELD THAT
LEFT YOU GRAVELY INJURED, GOD
BLESS YOU, YOU HAVE RECOVERED.
BUT LIFE CHANGING, YOUR
INJURIES.
ALALONG WITH SEVERAL OTHERS WHO
WERE HURT.
WHY THE PUSH NOW?
>> MY COLLEAGUBRAD WIN STRUP
WHO SAVED ME ON THAT BALLFIELD
HE STARTED ASKING DIRECTOR WRAY
WHY IT CLASSIFIED THIS AS
SUICIDE BY COP.
EVERYBODY WHO KNOWS WHAT
HAPPENED ON THAT BALL FIELD
KNOWS IT WASN’T SUICIDE BY COP.
HE WENT THERE TO KILL EVERY
REPUBLICAN AND HAD A LIST OF
NAMES OF OTHER REPUBLICANS I
WANTED TO KILL.
THANK GOD FOR THE HER HEROISM
OF CAPITAL POLICE.
THEY WERE PLAIN CLOTHES SO HE
DIDN’T KNOW THEY WERE COPS.
THEY GET INTO A SHOOT-OUT
TRYING.
HE WAS TRYING TO KILL THEM.
THEY BOTH GOT SHOT IN THE
SHOOT-OUT.
THAT’S NOT SUICIDE BY COP AND
THAT’S HOW IT’S CLASSIFIED BY
THE F.B.I.
OTHER AGENCIES HAVE CALLED IT
DOMS I CAN TERRORISM.
WE ASKED THE F.B.I. TO UPDATE
THE RECORD TO REFLECT IT
PROPERLY AND LET US KNOW WHY IT
WAS CLASSIFIED THAT WAY IN THE
FIRST PLACE WHEN EVERYBODY ELSE
WHO HAS GIVEN IT A
CLASSIFICATION CALLED IT
DOMESTIC TERRORISM.
>> Harris: IF YOU CAN TALK
ABOUT WHAT’S GOING ON IN ONE
PLACE WE CAN CERTAINLY LEARN
OUR LAWMAKERS AND POLICE
OFFICERS UNDER ATTACK IN
ANOTHER TO GET TO THE ANSWERS.
CONGRESSMAN SCALISE, GREAT TO
HAVE YOU ON THE PROGRAM.